anything about on that government
mandated shutdown us the small
businesses the decision between like
what's essential and what's not
I saw that you you retweeted Jeff Lewis
talking about
hey alcohol you know is
immunosuppressant but we have them open
I joked earlier there are a couple weeks
ago saying like it's funny how you can
still buy lottery tickets you can still
go buy alcohol you can do all the things
that drive government revenue I'm not
saying that they went into a room and
decided like let's keep our revenue
channels open but there's some
questionable things on what's essential
what's not like what's going on there
yeah I mean obviously this betrays the
idea that this is purely just a whole
character of a decision
Oh being you know a liquor store is
being opened it's really not a full
driven decision in this jump tweeted
correctly you know alcohol is an
immunosuppressant the last thing you
really want to do that you're optimizing
your health and your visa status trait
alcohol so I think that was done either
of core the political reality of
avoiding revolt with politicians are
very attuned to you if I take away
people's alcohol that are plain of wine
protest Souter Soapy's or maybe revenue
driven and a lot of it because all these
states are depend upon your sales of
liquor revenues or maybe both but it's
clearly not in the best interest we're
going to maximize the micellar of deaths
United States server here gonna keep
liquor stores open that seems kind of
silly I mean imagine like is so perverse
in California right now it is insane our
beaches are shut down our parks are shut
down and the liquor stores or globe will
be open that there's no rationality that
makes any sense behind any part of that
state and anybody who's you know people
should be really criticizing the
government and you still on this is yes
if you want to be a zero of defect and
we've actually still oscillations though
announcing out for net great
keep your parts of each is closed
and make people sit at home and you know
suffer but how the hell can you let them
go to liquor stores drink alcohol versus
going to a park for a walk out of height
6 feet apart for people yeah it's a it's
pretty crazy and I guess kind of going
off of that as well then is there's a
lot of businesses that let's say you're
a CVS you're Duane Reade so you get
lumped into hey you're an essential
business you're allowed to stay open but
the small business competitor in many
cases is being shut down or not allowed
to compete and it just feels like it's
very arbitrary right so I'm not even
saying that I've got an idea as to what
a better solution to determine it is it
just feels like once you step into the
game of playing kingmaker really right
saying hey your business has to shut
down but yours does and it's a slippery
slope that I just don't think that
there's a good answer but but I don't
know how you think about it there are
some lines that you know probably there
some there are clearly judgment or
judgment may be bias based lobbying
based for example anything he wants to
shut down the provision of food you know
food supplies it's over and so I think
there's not so there's always going to
be line-drawing
you know challenges and I think to some
extent the health like 50 different
states different communities within each
cake allowing them to draw different
lines and seeing what works all it does
it is a very thing with federal
assistant you know a lot of the more I'm
learning the benefits I don't lose them
for the first time on something for
thought certainly in high school and
they will cross over I'm saying law
school debate and you know constantly
the history of and learn the principle
legal principles process it behind but
it's still somewhat abstract and now
people are seeing you know why they'd be
better to have 50 laboratories of
democracy I think the Jeffersonian
phrase the show I think right now a lot
of regional variation experimentations
if it they get actually the fly
so obviously that government mandated
shutdown has created absolute economic
chaos we've seen 30 plus million
Americans final first-time unemployment
last six weeks you've got hundreds of
thousands if not millions of small
businesses that are shut down some
percentage are not coming back you've
got a number of industries that have
literally seen all of their economic
activity evaporate my favorite step was
the third week in March in 2019 US
domestic box office did 200 plus million
dollars in weekly revenue this year did
less than $5,000 right around $5,000 so
you got 99 percent you know evaporation
of revenue and the Fed steps in and they
stepped in with all kinds of actions
what's just high level good actions bad
actions how do you think about you know
their goal of trying to at least M some
of the issues and and relieve some of
the pain economic thinker and where
there's no price to these decisions but
how about is a price so clear so for
example you're already a block cap right
obviously period um no the problem
though we're not is not quite as years
of vitamin and other trends in American
history because the interest rate that
that debt current is so low so that one
of the things you care about is the debt
service love the right they like any
other company say that with the interest
rates too low the amount of repayment
for years are actually more tolerable
than it might seem
given the Congress to do that so to some
extent it's unclear how this all Nets
out
typically you know these are bad things
they ship generally you know just
burdens to generations but the
generations to Toronto
as well so I doesn't want to distort
things that are going on but in the
short term if the it feels like that has
minimized short-term impact on yes